[Music]
are you ready ready to climb ready to
climb let's climb I'm happy we made it
that was a good anniversary right dinner
to 100 more years 100 more years
[Music]
good morning today is gonna be a good
day we're going to have a great day
where are you going what are you doing
today is our officially our 10th
anniversary what did you plan Evan
stuff that you will see and enjoy and
first it's breakfast
we went to breakfast came back I changed
if you can see I guess not because I
only feel my face earlier now we're
gonna head up and have a great day
together
[Music]
we're going to the chandelier first but
first we need to figure it out how to
cross the the street because there's no
light or anything uh in that Circle so
we have we're walking on the ground to
the uh the tunnel not the tunnel the
subway Metro to find our way there
[Music]
so the OCTA triom is um there's some
they're having some issues it says it's
temporarily closed due to a social
movement
okay so
um so we're done here we're gonna head
to our next station not next station
next stop
foreign
pop-up Story the best great things
happen to us we're not the biggest
stranger things friend but the Hayden my
son is so we went in pictures had some
fun and uh we continue on
foreign
[Music]
yeah yeah I've never I've never been
here okay what makes you want to come
today spending 10 days with Nina and
Paris lets us do things that I've never
done before so it's good oh that's
pretty good I I just you know like I
like uh his Napoleon he ruled the world
you know well not not the whole world
but a good chunk of the world I like
seeing great people
doing great things inspires me to want
to change the world for the better this
is pretty good uh they probably could
have done more with with the
storytelling and the entrance and
everything but whatever I'm happy you
made it next stop Eiffel Tower and uh
probably a cafe or break along the way
[Music]
so we have about 45 minutes to kill
before we cut up to the Eiffel Tower so
we're gonna grab some snacks and a
coffee and chill a little bit because my
calves are hurting so we got two coffee
with cream and has heart on the top
toast with avocado we have the heaven
order the same thing we're about to
climb the Eiffel Towers we need a little
bit of food before we started
it's good
the snacks uh I really liked it yeah
Nina didn't think it was enough no
because I'm still hungry yeah I'm pretty
full I like it it was fresh I like the
coffee I like the sitting down I like
the avocado I like the salad I like it
but Nina wants more so yeah let's see if
we can find her a baguette
so I did a quick stop at this pastry
place I got a baguette
and croissant
foreign
[Music]
ready to climb let's climb climbing
shoes on we're ready
and now we're later we finally get to
climb the stairs
ready for stair seven
all right we're only on the first floor
I'm tired guys
we walk halfway through my legs is like
oh my God I was like juggling
I have to hold the rail to climb up to
the first floor okay I don't know we'll
see how long the lineup to the elevator
maybe take the elevator up
foreign
that was fun
got some relaxing and
relax a little bit took some pictures
yeah yeah we took the elevator all the
way down those stairs yeah yeah he's
happy yeah I can't take any more stairs
in it yeah so tonight it's anniversary
dinner so we're going on a on a river
boat cruise while we eat dinner very
exciting we have
over two hours before we leave so we
have to one just go find out where we're
going and then to go back to the hotel
Nina wants to shower freshen up whatever
she wants to do and then dinner time
Cruise time anniversary time let's go
all right got back change oh my goodness
a little bit of makeup
did they see the whole outfit no no and
now we're gonna show them the whole
outfit it's okay we're going for a boat
cruise dinner cruise with my wife of 10
years let's go
this is our boat we're going to be
having dinner on here cruising down the
Sand River we start right across from
the Eiffel Tower and Nina's vlogging it
too I should I should have found you
okay while you talk about that okay yeah
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna get
on this boat and then uh they're gonna
leave in half an hour
[Music]
this is uh Sue try Evan
it's good yummy oh it's creamy it's like
um
cream of
chicken or carrot
oh yeah
I always get for grass
I don't know it's just like it's very
creamy and Rich
Evan got escargot
[Music]
Nina's trying her foie gras
all right Evan and I we have the same
thing
it's good
good choice you did a good job
[Music]
if you like it yeah good you pick this
place remember good job
[Music]
that was a good anniversary right dinner
yeah thank you so much for planning this
oh wow okay I appreciate it if it's Levy
for me it would have been great if you
did it it would have been great but we
did it thank you
look behind us you want to show people
romantic
to 100 more years 100 more years
of course of course of course okay
camera off we've got some work to do
it's the next morning yeah
if you want to know what we do today
click the video right there it's the
lead we'll see you there